have breaking news from the White House
where Admiral Ronnie Jackson is
withdrawing his nomination to be
Veterans Affairs Secretary Jackson the
chief White House doctor released a
statement minutes ago announcing his
withdrawal and strongly criticizing
unconfirmed allegations of on-the-job
misconduct Jackson wrote the allegations
against me are completely false and
fabricated if they had any merit I would
not have been selected promoted and
entrusted to serve in such a sensitive
and important role as physician to three
presidents over the past twelve years
major Garrett is at the White House
major good morning so why didn't he stay
in fight because the political climate
on Capitol Hill even among Senate
Republicans was simply not receptive
Senate Republicans were not going to
stand alongside dr. Jackson and push him
through this confirmation process I
reported last night that the White House
was bracing itself for Jackson to
withdraw we talked about that at the
seven o'clock hour and in fact that is
what has come Jackson said in his
statement that because of the way
Washington works he's become a
distraction well inside the White House
just a couple of days ago a senior
official was telling me that the White
House did a quote horrible job preparing
Jackson's story for Senate confirmation
hearings that he wasn't given the
backing of the White House on once these
allegations emerged he was essentially
defenseless and in that defenseless
context the political environment turned
against him rapidly the White House
could not marshal a sufficiently strong
11th hour counter narrative and that is
why Jackson seeing that he had no real
path to confirmation no real path even
to a fair confirmation hearing withdrew
in order to keep his White House job as
the White House doctor to be determined
that is something that is certainly
available to him if the president wants
to keep him and he wants to stay in that
role that's not part of the statement
we'll find out all right thank you very
much major Garrett reporting with
breaking news